[Musique]
regarde aujourd'hui ce nouveau samsung
galaxy note jean qui est présenté en
avant première à l'ifa c'est un produit
qui est vraiment très sympa alors qu'en
terme de taz patients bien content si on
compare la taille avec un iphone 7
forcément c'est la gamme note c'est
beaucoup plus grand côté écran vous avez
un micro infiniti 6,3 pouces quad hd
super amoled
c'est vraiment un écran extrêmement
confortable très pratique
c'est vraiment à mon sens un des plus
beaux écrans avec le lgv 30 qui m'a
carrément bluffé pour moi celui ci c'est
vraiment un produit qui est traîtresse
un drap très agréable à regarder et le
bord à bord c'est toujours demain un
produit qui est quand même assez fins
bord à bord c'est vrai que votre fait
radier un côté bord à bord
avait deux capteurs à l'arrière puis
inventant goujon mégapixels et un
téléobjectif également aux 10 mégapixels
vous permet de jouer sur la profondeur
de champ lorsque vous
faites des photos c'est un produit qui
se débrouille aussi exactement
ariary c'est alors qu'on peut regretter
souvent celle un confort parce que
lorsque vous cherchez à dioro ici vous
allez nous ce qui est posé votre doigt
sur la caméra et du coup grâce à lire
c'est un petit peu le point négatif de
ce projet
vous avez ici votre slot pour ajouté
remettre votre carte sim pour ajouter
votre extension ont jusqu'à 256 gibier
en termes de mémoire interne
vous pouvez quand même mettre pas mal de
stockage dedans donc c'est vrai que ça
se tient bien c'est plutôt sympa bien
évidemment un bouton
le bouton pour l'allumer vous avez
entreprise jacques il se charge quand on
y est blessé c'est vrai que c'est un
produit qui est quand même extrêmement
sa maman avec vous avez le s pen est ici
alors que seulement ici tout est attaché
donc et fo tirent un petit peu mais
c'est un produit qui se compteraient
très bien tendre avec c'est quand même
très très agréable en france vont
dessiner c'est très léger c'est plutôt
compact
pas positif le galaxy note suite et
résistant à la poussière et à l'eau
parce qu'il ya une certification il fait
68 retrouve également ici lâche pas s'y
connaît bien la caméra de face qui va
permettre une reconnaissance faciale
reconnaissance de l'iris aussi pour
déverrouiller nouvelle déverrouiller
comme sa reconnaissance faciale
reconnaissance de l'iris avec dans le
capteur d'empreintes digitales derrière
vous pouvez saisir un code et vous
pouvez aussi faire le dessin comment ça
s'appelle retroussant les sur les
samsung ont dimension c'est un produit
qui fait 162,5 pas 74,8 et une épaisseur
de 8,6 tout ça bien sûr sondés mm à
l'avant ce qu'on peut regretter
effectivement sur un produit comme celui
là comme sur tous les smartphones en ce
moment c'est à dire que vous avez
uniquement un appareil photo de 8
mégapixels à l'avant ce qui fait que
lorsque vous voulez faire du live
streaming sur youtube
vous filmez avec un moyen pour pouvoir
vous regardez et bien vous n'avez pas
une qualité optimale c'est à mon sens
une autorité sur tous les smartphones
lecture si on compare par exemple lgv 30
qui va sortir au mois de mai quand vous
avez une caméra 5 mégapixels à l'avant
et ça c'est vraiment dommage conteste
les constructeurs vont enfin nous mettre
d excellentes caméras sur le devant un
prétoire effectivement la plupart des
gens ce film et créer des live c'est
finalement et ont besoin d'un moniteur
sur le processeur ou lundi mm offre
d'accord on a vraiment une machine qui
tourne bien sympa qui répond extrêmement
bien on peut faire plein de choses à
faire rapidement
c'est un produit qui à mon sens de bonne
qualité retrouverez - les
caractéristiques du galaxy s suite en
plus grand avec un petit peu plus de
mémoire par contre en terme de prise en
main en terme de qualité d'écran c'est
vrai que ce format
si la bulle 3 pouces est vraiment très
très agréable produits qui a si giga de
ram
côté batterie aurait une 3300 millions
terreur on sait que la bâtisse est ce
qui avait causé un vrai fiasco au niveau
du galaxy note cet immense galaxie no 2
suit avec les batteries trois mille
trois cent mille intérieur pour les
malheurs appris la crainte que peut
avoir c'est d'avoir une batterie un
petit peu trop légère qu'un rapport à la
consommation de l'écran mais par rapport
à l'utilisation de ce produit mais je
pense qu'on n'a pas à s'inquiéter parce
que samsung a vraiment optimisé le
produit pour ne pas consommer énormément
moment les batteries de 3300 milan
terreur ça devient carrément le job bien
évidemment on a de lui et se dessiner
c'est un produit qu'on recharge par
induction fait vous avez une recharge
rapide
quelque chose de très pratique en
produits pour résumer qui admire son
soutien bien un écran très très agréable
à l'écran infiniti c'est vraiment sympa
point négatif la caméra de phrases qui
effectivement les principes à reformater
le deal et ruia the dozen mettez votre
vie un cône important c'est un peu le un
peu le souci de se produire sinon c'est
un produit qui est très sympa mais ce
que vous en pensez en commentaires qu'on
n'a pas je trouve que c'est un bon
produit si vous cherchez un produit avec
un stylet avec un grand écran
les galaxy note 8 faire la job mais pas
tous en commun car il ya ma patrie salut
[Musique]